I reject nation it's Greg Alba here I'm
John we're gonna watch a video today
patron video request time CEO burger
patron we do TV show reactions for many
of shows such as my hero academia Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood attack on
Titan Gotham Riverdale and supernatural
we also do weekly q and A's as well one
of our reward tiers is whatever video
you request we must definitely cover for
the youtubes and today comes from a man
named Lance door handsome-looking mother
if firefighter he wants us to check out
this video folks are are knots extended
edition I've never seen the original
edition nor have I seen the extended
edition so this should be fun hey let's
just hop right it to this yeah of course
of course he's real
now I miss this movie so did you have
for breakfast I was asking you what you
eat because what I look at you
guess what I see I'll tell you they're
gonna cream cheese but never to do it a
frowny biscuit
how long would it take to get market
first expected your hit on the stock
exchange it didn't work my friend and
now you have my construction crews going
around the city looking for strawberries
strawberries it seems that you do not
appreciate me a demonstration this is
your body
it seems like a guy wouldn't care what
about his five rooms
got wanna watch this movie again an
element in the IMAX
my mother warned me about getting into
college the students man this is it
[Music]
Oh
that's right
jiggle
[Music]
I listen to some play cruise around guys
it's actually over oh yeah it's so fun
some of the jokes don't fully it but I
love that rig is that first joke about
strawberry and fibers like what yeah
yeah I thought little thing but then it
just kept going it's character specs a
lot that and freestyle rapping oh the
Freestyle it was so funny I love what I
like this childish version of bein
generally rides with like a high school
jock well yeah because it seems like
everything he's effectively doing is
just as devastating as it was in the
movie he just doesn't seem ultimately
that concerned because he's more
concerned with his diet
yeah he's more concerned about looking
good having skills he just wants to be
the best version of something upon this
seemed like the high school version of
these two were going to war because even
with Batman getting in the is whatever
the bad lighting yeah and then Mortal
Kombat music yeah you know which I don't
know if I was Batman I would turn on
some tunes while I'm just in route to
some crime or some the comedy image is
just
is to like they call themselves the are
all nots and I gotta give them props
because the sound is mixed pretty well
in this and likes like bad lip reading
this thing yeah yeah but there's also
some stuff where especially with the
music where they're utilizing the cuts
that the movie has so it's like you know
you cut to a farther off shot like the
music gets lowered so it makes it feel
that much more real I admire those
little flourishes too just because you
know sound can you know a lot for a
comedy i want this version of bane I
want anything I want to I want to hold
character of a movie you're not talking
about any kind of domination plots or
anything like doing the same [__] but
he's always breaking down I feel like
just the extra layer that would have
added to it is Bane is really like he
has ways to go of being in better shape
because he's kind of like a fat buff guy
he's got a belly
yeah his whole body's a hybrid of muscle
and fat he seems like he carbo-load the
law for someone to point out how he's is
kind of not in the best shape yeah all
about this healthy level of fiber like
well you take that much fiber yeah and
then that would lend itself perfectly to
like an 80s style montage where Bane
really hits the gym and like really
starts working out and get lean and
stuff like that I think that would be
really inspiring would have been
perfecto in my opinion oh yeah plus it
would make him that much more scary does
he know he's ready and I'd also like to
see Bane and Batman do a reading of pulp
fiction if the cops stop you it's
illegal for them to search you I mean
that's a right the cuffs and Amsterdam
don't have oh man I'm going that's all
there is to it a [__] gory
I know baby you did get the most and you
know what they call the quarter pounder
with cheese in Paris they don't call it
a quarter pounder with cheese no man
they got the metric system there they
wouldn't know what the [__] a quarter
pounder is what they call it they call
it a Royale which is Royale which
eze yeah that's right well they call it
Big Mac well Big Macs a Big Mac but I'll
call it low Big Mac let Big Mac what did
he call a whopper I don't know I didn't
go in to Burger King
well you know what they put on french
fries in Holland instead of ketchup
what mayonnaise Oh
if there's anyone I know it takes a lot
of fiber though it's Lance door
definitely you can't afford to have to
poop when you're putting out a fire the
thing is Lance has a girl there's a
child too
Lance is telling me in messages this is
very private stuff and I hate to tell
everyone but I'm going to anyway
there's only alone time is when he gets
to poop so what he's constantly doing is
just taking a lot of fiber going to the
bathroom and staying on the toilet
watching the Schmo down watching the
real rejects it's his only time he gets
some silence and away time he's also a
firefighter and you know you know boys
of fire fighting stations could be
whacking each other in the garage all
day amen
firefighter during the day fiber fighter
in the back yeah exactly so he just has
the time to chill out poop a lot and
because he's able to poop son Lance
Poole do a second draft on this I feel
like he probably has like a bein like
body just with bigger glutes than bane
cuz you know as a firefighter you have
to climb a lot of things yeah yeah doing
squats man get that get that bubble butt
going on a dude glance I appreciate you
sending me a photo of your ass is good
ass nice holes in there
and multiples that's any more
information on you now what are you make
this shout out easier hey subscribe to
the hour all knots and you can subscribe
to us and check us out on patreon bye
bye